.
GAYLE?
>> ALL RIGHT.
WEIJIA JIANG, THANK YOU.
A LOT TO TALK ABOUT THERE.
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY JEN
PSAKI JOINS US TO BRING US UP TO
DATE ON THE LATEST, WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN THE BIDEN WHITE
HOUSE.
LISTEN, I KNOW THIS IS GOING TO
BE A VERY LONG DAY FOR ME.
SOMETHING TELLS ME YOU LIKE LONG
DAYS, WE THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME.
>> I DO, GAYLE.
A SECRET IS I'M WEARING
COMFORTABLE SHOES NOW.
YOU CAN'T SEE THEM.
IT'S A BIG DAY AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, NO QUESTION.
>> BIG NIGHT FOR TEAM BIDEN.
LET'S START WITH RAISING THE
TAXES ON THE WEALTHY.
I CAN ENVISION A LOT OF WEALTHY
PEOPLE GOING, HUH, COME AGAIN,
WHAT DID YOU SAY?
ON PAPER, YOU DON'T APPEAR TO
HAVE GOP SUPPORT FOR THAT.
SO HOW WILL YOU GUYS PULL THAT
OFF?
YOU NEED THE GOP SUPPORT.
>> SURE, GAYLE, WE DO.
BUT FIRST, THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING HERE IS THIS IS A REALLY
BOLD PROPOSAL.
THE AMERICAN FAMILIES PLAN.
THE AMERICAN FAMILIES PLAN IS
GOING TO ENSURE THAT KIDS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, FAMILIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY GET FOUR YEARS OF
PRE-K, THAT'S NOT A PARTISAN
PROPOSAL.
THAT'S SOMETHING PEOPLE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY REALLY COULD BENEFIT
FROM.
BUT THE PRESIDENT BELIEVES WE
SHOULD PROPOSE A WAY TO P FOR
IT.
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
RAISING THE TOP RATE, THE TOP
TAX RATES FOR 1% OF AMERICANS.
1%.
THE TOP RATE, GOING BACK TO WHAT
THE RATES WERE DURING FORMER
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH'S
PRESIDENCY TO HELP PAY FOR THAT.
WE THINK THEY CAN AFFORD TO DO
THAT.
>> WE KEEP HEARING THAT THERE
ARE MEETINGS BEHIND THE SCENES
BETWEEN REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS.
JOE BIDEN SAID HE WANTED TO BE A
UNIFIER.
SO FAR PEOPLE SAY THAT'S NOT
WORKING OUT SO WELL.
ARE THERE ANY REPUBLICANS YOU
CAN SINGLE OUT WHO YOU SAY
BEHIND THE SCENES ARE REALLY
BEING VERY HELPFUL IN THIS?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK IT WOULD
BE HELPFUL TO THEM IF I CALLED
THEM OUT.
BUT I WILL SAY, GAYLE, THAT THE
WAY THE PRESIDENT LOOKS AT
BIPARTISANSHIP AND BRINGING THE
COUNTRY TOGETHER IS HAVING
AMERICAN PEOPLE RECEIVING AND
DIGESTING THINGS.
AND THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN,
THE MAJORITY OF THE PUBLIC
SUPPORTED THAT.
THE MAJORITY OF THE PUBLIC WANTS
TO HAVE LOWER AND MIDDLE-INCOME
FAMILIES TO HAVE ACCESS TO
UNIVERSAL PRE-K.
THESE ARE THINGS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE NEED, THEY WANT, THEY
DESERVE.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BRINGING
TOGETHER MEMBERS IN WASHINGTON.
THAT'S ALSO IMPORTANT.
THERE WAS A PROPOSAL, A
COUNTERPROPOSAL JUST LAST WEEK
PRESENTED FROM SOME REPUBLICANS,
AND WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
HAVING A DISCUSSION ABOUT WHERE
WE CAN FINE AGREEMENT MOVING
FORWARD.
I EXPECT THE PRESIDENT WILL
INVITE MEMBERS DOWN TO THE WHITE
HOUSE NEXT WEEK.
>> I WANT TO SHIFT GEARS TO THE
FIGHT AGAINST THE CORONAVIRUS.
THE RATE OF DAILY VACCINATIONS
IN AMERICA HAS FALLEN IN RECENT
DAYS, DOWN TO ABOUT 2.7 MILLION
FROM A HIGH OF 3.4.
ARE WE FALLING OFF TRACK?
IN OTHER WORDS, ARE WE STILL ON
TRACK FOR A JULY 4th RETURN TO
NORMALCY AS THE WHITE HOUSE
WOULD HOPE?
>> WE ABSOLUTELY ARE, TONY.
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTNT POINT
BECAUSE WE'VE SHIFTED ABOUT LAST
WEEK, WE SHIFTED FROM A PLACE OF
BEING CONCERNED ABOUT SUPPLY TO
REALLY BEING FOCUSED ON MEETING
PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE.
WE KNOW AT THIS POINT THAT ALL
OF OUR ENERGIES AND EFFORTS FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE, FROM THE
GOVERNMENT, FROM THE COVID TEAM
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH GOVERNORS
AND PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS IS
TO REALLY MEET PEOPLE WHERE THEY
ARE, GET TO THOSE COMMUNITIES
WHERE PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED,
WHERE THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT
TAKING A DAY OFF OF WORK, WHERE
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO GET THE
VACCINE.
WE'VE MASSIVELY EXPANDED THE
NUMBER OF PHARMACI, NOW
40,000.
WE'RE PARTNERING AS OF LAST WEEK
WITH LOCAL DOCTORS.
AND WE'RE REALLY WORKING TO GET
TO PEOPLE AND LET THEM KNOW THIS
IS EFFECTIVE, IT'S GOING TO HELP
YOU NOT WEAR A MASK OUTSIDE, AS
WE JUST ANNOUNCED YESTERDAY.
AND YOU KNOW, THIS IS THE STAGE
WE ALWAYS EXPECTED WE'D BE IN AT
THIS POINT IN TIME.
>> JEN, WE AND OTHER NETWORKS
KEEP TALKING ABOUT HOW THERE'S A
CORE GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
INTENDING TO GET VACCINATED, AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY THOSE ARE
REPUBLICANS.
IN OUR POLL, ABOUT 30% OF
REPUBLICANS SAY THEY DO NOT
INTEND TO GET VACCINATED.
IS THERE A PLAN TO BRING THEM ON
BOARD?
OR WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS,
IS THE MATHEMATICAL REALITY YOU
DON'T NEED THEM?
>> WELL, WE ALWAYS WANT TO GET
AS MANY PEOPLE VACCINATED AS WE
CAN.
THAT'S NOT A POLITICAL QUESTION.
BUT I WOULD SAY, TONY, THAT
WE'VE SEEN SOME -- THE
ENCOURAGING NEWS I SHOULD SAY IS
THAT WE'VE SEEN SOME
IMPROVEMENTS, SOME INCREASED
LEVELS OF CONFIDENCE AMONG MORE
CONSERVATIVE WHITE REPUBLICANS.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN AN INCREASE IN
CONFIDENCE AMONG BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES, AS MORE OF THEIR
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS GET
VACCINATED.
AND THE WAY THAT WE'RE INVESTING
THE $3 BILLION THAT WE'RE DOING
THROUGH HEALTH AND HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES, GETTING OUT TO
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
IS WE'RE REALLY EMPOWERING AND
HELPING TO FUND LOCAL DOCTORS,
CIVIC LEADERS, CLERGY.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE ME OR EVEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN TELLING PEOPLE
GET THE VACCINE WHO DOESN'T
AGREE WITH THEM, IT'S GOING TO
BE PEOPLE THEY TRUST IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
THAT'S REALLY WHERE OUR FOCUS IS
AT THIS POINT.
>> YEAH.
JEN, WHEN IT COMES TO MONEY,
RIGHT NOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS FOOTING THE BILL FOR EVERY
SINGLE VACCINE FOR EVERY
AMERICAN.
WE KEEP HEARING ABOUT BOOSTER
SHOTS IN YEARS TO COME.
IS THE GOVERNMENT GOING TO PAY
INDEFINITELY?
OR IS THIS GOING TO BE A POINT
AT WHICH IT STOPS?
>> WELL, FIRST, THE FDA IS STILL
REVIEWING THE NEED FOR A BOOSTER
SHOT.
WE ARE OVERPREPARERS,
OVERSUPPLIERS, THAT'S OUR JOB.
WE'RE GOING TO ORDER ENOUGH
SUPPLY TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
THAT SHOULD WE NEED IT.
WE'RE NOT AT THAT POINT YET.
WE'LL HAVE TO DETERMINE LOU
WIDELY IT'S NEEDED, HOW
FREQUENTLY, AND MAKE AN
ASSESSMENT OF HOW WE CAN ASSURE
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE PUBLIC
GETS ACCESS.
>> 100 DAYS, BIG NIGHT.
I'M SURE YOU'RE DOTTING THE Is
AND CROSSING THE Ts,HAT GRADE
ARE YOU GIVING YOURSELVES, I
KNOW IT'S EARLY, THE FIRST 100
DAYS?
>> LOOK, I WILL LET OTHERS
GRADE.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT -- I
WILL TELL YOU THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S FOCUS COMING IN, ALL
OF OUR FOCUSES WAS ON GETTING
THE PANDEMIC UNDER CONTROL,
PUTTING PEOPLE BACK TO WORK.
WE PASSED A HISTORIC PLAN, THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN, THAT'S
GOING TO HELP PEOPLE WITH THAT
BRIDGE.
BUT ALSO MORE THAN 200 MILLION
PEOPLE, SHOTS HAVE BEEN PUT INTO
ARMS.
WE'VE FEEL PRETTY GOOD ABOUT
THAT.
>> OKAY.
GIVE YOURSELF A GRADE, JEN --
GIVE YOURSELF A GRADE.
>> I'M NOT HERE TO GIVE GRADES.
I'LL LET OTHERS GIVE US GRADES.
YOU CAN GIVE US GRADES.
I WILL SAY WHAT -- PEOPLE WILL
HEAR FROM HIM TONIGHT IS NOT
JUST HOW FAR WE'VE COME BUT THE
FACT THE GOVERNMENT CAN WORK.
DEMOCRACY CAN WORK.
NOW'S THE TIME TO BE BOLD.
THE AMERICAN FAMILIES PLAN IS
PART OF THAT PLAN.
BUT HE IS ALSO GOING TO TALK
ABOUT POLICE REFORMS WE NEEDED,
THE NEED TO PUT GUN SAFETY
MEASURES IN PLACE, IMMIGRATION.
THAT'S ALL GOING TO BE IN HIS
SPEECH, TOO.
>> POLICE REFORM IS VERY
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW.
THE COUNTRY'S --
>> NO QUESTION.
>> THE COUNTRY'S NOT IN A GOOD
PLACE ON THAT ISSUE RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU, JEN PSAKI, GOOD TO
SEE YOU.
>> GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> BYE-BYE.
>>> AND WE WILL BRING YOU A
SPECIAL REPORT ON THE
PRESIDENT'S ADDRESS TO CONGRESS
TONIGH